[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines tout de suite
les titres de ce jeudi 27 avril
décrypter les nouveaux codes de la
beauté c'est le thème imposé par le
groupe L'Oréal comme chaque année des
milliers d'étudiants participent au
concours L'Oréal brainstorm le but cette
année proposait des innovations en
utilisant des technologies comme la
réalité virtuelle ou encore le metaves
Marie Landrevie originaire de Poissy
représentera la France en demi-finale du
concours mondial elle est notre invité
comment bien planter ses fleurs c'est la
question que se pose de nombreux
jardiniers amateurs avec l'arrivée du
printemps l'arboretum de Versailles
chèvreloux au Chesnay rock en cours
propose des ateliers pour apprendre à
cultiver vos fleurs se mis à la volée
entérine ou en plaques alvéolée on vous
dit tout des techniques de jardinage
dans cette édition
et puis comme chaque jeudi nos idées de
sortie pour le week-end balade en vélo à
Versailles maison des insectes à
carrière sous Poissy ou encore chasse
aux œufs à Rambouillet nous vous dirons
tout pour profiter au mieux de ce
weekend prolongé
et puis en plateau avec moi Marie
landrevy bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
étudiante à l'ESSEC et vous participez
au concours L'Oréal brainstorm donc ce
concours challenge toute personne ayant
30 ans ou moins en souhaitant qui
souhaite innover dans le secteur de la
beauté et votre équipe avec votre équipe
vous avez créé you are modèle en
quelques mots qu'est-ce que c'est alors
you are modèle c'est l'expérience
e-commerce 2.0 pour que chaque
consommateur beauté devienne le
personnage principal de son expérience
shopping sur les sites e-commerce de
L'Oréal très bien merci et donc du coup
si on y revient un peu plus en détail
donc vous utilisez de l'intelligence
artificielle alors on utilise un donc on
va c'est pas encore développer mais on
veut utiliser voilà une combinaison de
trois technologies donc modify et le
machine learning pour que le visage du
consommateur puisse apparaître sur
chaque page produit sur les sites
internet bien merci Marie Landreville on
en reparlera plus amplement tout à
l'heure et puis à vos côtés Gérald de
doukam bonsoir alors vous êtes récemment
lancé dans l'entrepreneuriat et vous
avez créé votre micro entreprise alpha 7
drone qui propose des prestations de
vieux aériennes pourquoi est-ce que vous
êtes lancé dans cette activité alors en
fait je me suis lancé dans cette
activité parce que ça fait une vingtaine
d'années que j'étais salarié en tant que
d'agent de sécurité incendie chef de
site donc je dirigeais des personnes et
en fait j'ai voulu j'ai voulu me lancer
un nouveau défi de créer d'être mon
propre patron et de créer mon entreprise
alpha 7 drone et bien on a hâte d'en
découvrir un peu plus en face de vous
Céline Charles bonsoir bonsoir aussi
journaliste de la rédaction 70 TV 78 et
avec vous nous verrons ce qu'il faut
retenir de l'actualité du jour dans les
Yvelines mais avant tout un petit point
sur la météo de demain
[Musique]
le ciel est très chargé dans tout le
département avec quelques précipitations
attendues dans la matinée du côté des
températures la douceur s'installe avec
14 degrés à ou dans Versailles et
Rambouillet et 15 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
ciel se dégage avec des éclaircies
partout dans le département au niveau
des températures on gagne entre 3 et 4
degrés avec 17 degrés à Rambouillet et
Versailles et 18 degrés à Houdan et
Mantes-la-Jolie et demain ce sera la
saint Valérie tout de suite le point de
vue sur l'actualité du jour dans les
Yvelines
et on commence avec vous Céline Charles
et cette information 300 agents d'enedis
se sont rassemblés devant le château de
Versailles ce matin contre la réforme
des retraites oui vous allez le voir sur
les images près de 200 véhicules se sont
stationnés en fil indienne sur l'avenue
de Paris devant l'entrée du château de
Versailles une mobilisation à l'appel de
la CGT qui rassemblée des agents des
Yvelines des Hauts-de-Seine du
Val-de-Marne et de l'Essonne le convoi
s'est ensuite rendu à Saint-Cyr-l'École
et Guyancourt pour une opération
escargot une contestation vous le savez
qui continue puisque l'Inter syndicale
prépare une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation le 1er mai attention si
vous prévoyez de partir ou revenir de
vacances le secteur des transports sera
touché l'aviation civile à notamment
demander aux compagnies aériennes
d'annuler 33% de leur vol à Paris Orly
et 25% à Roissy et pour les plus
gourmands de nos téléspectateurs le
concours de la meilleure baguette de
tradition des Yvelines a rendu son
verdict oui cette fois-ci avis aux fans
de pain et surtout de la baguette de
tradition chaque année des concours
gourmand récompense les meilleurs de
chaque département francilien et c'est à
la Chambre des métiers de l'artisanat de
Versailles que le président de la
Fédération des boulangers des Yvelines a
rendu public les délibérations du jury
pour la catégorie chef d'entreprise
c'est Julien Duhamel de la boulangerie
pâtisserie créateur de gourmandise à
Orgeval dans la catégorie salariée c'est
David Babin de la boulangerie pâtisserie
maison Xavier à Triel-sur-Seine et enfin
dans la catégorie des apprentis c'est
jade Hernando de la boulangerie
pâtisserie roi d'or à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux et un nouveau
pensionnaire a fait son entrée au zoo de
Thoiry tout à fait Régine on souhaite la
bienvenue à Jabou un éléphant d'Afrique
mâle de 9 ans il est arrivé jeudi 20
avril après un long voyage de près de
trois jours depuis le zoo de Boras en
Suède le Pachyderm a ensuite été déposé
dans son enclos à l'aide d'une grue
parce qu'il pèse tout de même près de 10
tonnes j'avoue vient rejoindre deux
autres éléphants ben l'éléphant
historique du zoo de 42 ans et maillot 9
ans arrivait l'été dernier la mise en
contact a été faite et tout s'est très
bien passé et avis maintenant au
passionné physique régime comme vous le
savez sûrement la fête de la musique se
déroulera comme chaque année le 21 juin
prochain et pour l'occasion plusieurs
villes des Yvelines rejettent activement
leurs talents musicaux pour la soirée à
Coignières par exemple les musiciens et
chanteurs amateurs ou professionnels ont
jusqu'au 3 mai pour envoyer leurs
dossier de candidature il faudra ensuite
passer par l'étape d'une audition le 16
mai à 19h à l'Espace Daudet à plaisir
vous avez jusqu'au 5 mai et les
sélections se feront court en juin la
ville de Trappes attend également vos
candidatures n'hésitez pas à vous
renseigner auprès de votre municipalité
pour les modalités d'inscription et on
termine avec les prévisions de
circulation ça risque d'être assez
compliqué en Île-de-France ce week-end
ce week-end c'est le chasser croisé des
vacances pour la zone C mais c'est aussi
un week-end de trois jours avec le lundi
1er mai pour demain vendredi 28
l'Île-de-France est classée rouge par
Bison Futé dans le sens des départs les
premiers ralentissements sont attendus
pour la fin de matinée notamment en
direction des barrières de péage de
l'autoroute A10 il vous est donc plutôt
conseillé de quitter ou traverser la
région avant midi 29 le niveau de trafic
sera globalement moins important mais la
région est tout de même classée orange
prévoyait de partir avant 8h enfin lundi
1er c'est dans le sens des retours que
la circulation sera difficile en
Île-de-France prévoyait si possible un
retour avant 14h et bien merci Céline
Charles pour ses actualités et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous êtes
témoin d'un fait qui vous a marqué près
de chez vous n'hésitez pas à le partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news
et on en parlait en début d'émission le
groupe L'Oréal organise depuis plus de
30 ans un concours mondial d'innovation
ce concours met en compétition des
candidats du monde entier pour proposer
des innovations de demain dans le
secteur de la beauté et Marie
Landreville vous y participer avec votre
équipe vous avez proposé you are modèle
donc c'est une technologie qui utilise
l'intelligence artificielle et elle
permet donc à un utilisateur de plaudé
une photo de lui sur un site e-commerce
et de pouvoir tester les produits
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez décidé de
lancer de vous lancer sur ce projet
alors donc déjà il faut savoir que la
compétition du Lorraine winstorm c'est
une conviction qui est assez connue donc
en école de commerce parce qu'on est
toutes les trois donc Sophie Martinez
pierre on est tous les trois à sec donc
c'est une compétition qui est assez
connue et qu'on aime bien faire parce
que c'est challengeance et toujours
voilà histoire de repousser ses limites
donc on nous a proposé une problématique
qui était de donc de créer une
expérience consommateur
donc pour L'Oréal en utilisant les
technologies du web 3 donc ça va être la
réalité augmentée l'intelligence
artificielle le méta verse etc et donc
c'était très large et c'était à nous en
fait de d'un peu de de créer notre
propre problématique et donc on a
vraiment essayé de trouver un sujet qui
nous tenait à coeur et qui pour nous
était vraiment important donc on a
vraiment on a vraiment cherché ensemble
et donc on a décidé de de toucher à
l'inclusivité donc un gros problème pour
nous c'est que même si voilà les
couleurs de peau etc sont de plus en
plus représentées pour nous en fait il
faut aller encore un pas plus loin voir
même deux voire même trois donc en fait
c'est de voilà de de surpasser
l'utilisation des mannequins et que le
consommateur devienne en fait le
mannequin donc pour ses yeux seulement
mais voilà plus se sentir représenté
parce qu'en fait on s'est dit la
meilleure façon de se sentir représenté
de se sentir représenté pardon c'est de
se voir soi-même donc donc voilà on a
essayé de développer un peu une
technologie pour pour répondre à ce
problème et donc c'est quelque chose qui
vous intéressait vous plus
particulièrement est-ce que c'est aussi
quelque chose qui était intégré dans
votre programme scolaire ou pas du tout
alors ça a été intégré dans notre
programme scolaire on a eu donc on a une
compétition qui s'appelle la Digital
week elle est sec ou on a pu travailler
pour L'Oréal travailler c'est un très
grand mot mais on a pu faire un projet
pour L'Oréal et donc il nous avait
proposé une problématique assez
similaire et ensuite ils nous ont
encouragé à pousser notre projet donc le
présenter sur cette compétition
internationale ce qu'on a fait parce
qu'on a été hyper motivé on a adoré
l'expérience donc on a voulu pour suivre
et justement ce concept des sièges
virtuels il existe déjà on a pu le voir
notamment avec modify pourquoi enfin
qu'est-ce qui fait l'originalité
finalement de votre projet aujourd'hui
alors du coup modify pour ceux qui
connaissent un peu moins en fait c'est
du virtual schwarion donc quand on va
sur un sur un site internet maintenant
on a la chance de pouvoir voilà essayer
avec sa caméra et voir un peu ce que le
produit pourrait ressembler sur sur
notre visage après ça assez limite c'est
à dire que quand on voilà quand on est
sur le site internet de Maybelline bah
parfois on est dans le train parfois on
est dans son lit et donc bah voilà tout
le tout le background la luminosité est
pas forcément optimale et donc parfois
ça peut donner un contenu qui est pas
forcément très représentatif de la
réalité ou très professionnel et en plus
de ça il faut prendre une photo ou un
scanner à chaque fois qu'on veut aussi
un nouveau produit et donc nous on veut
vraiment proposer une expérience 360 qui
s'arrête jamais on veut voilà un scan du
visage et tout le site le site internet
se synchronise pour que le visage du
consommateur apparaissent sur les pages
produits donc avec les angles parfaits
la luminosité parfaite pour vraiment
avoir un contenu professionnel et hyper
représentatif de la réalité et du coup
ça sera utilisable sur le site de
L'Oréal puisque il y aura aussi d'autres
marques qui pourront utiliser ça ou
alors du coup notre projet pour
l'instant on est parti sur la marque
maybuline évidemment c'est qu'un projet
c'est une proposition donc on est parti
sur la marque Maybelline qui fait
beaucoup de make-up et qui cible surtout
les les jeunes aides parce qu'on s'est
dit que potentiellement c'était une
technologie qui pouvait peut-être les
mettre plus à l'aise et que voilà une
tranche une tranche de population
peut-être un peu moins à l'aise avec la
technologie etc après évidemment le but
c'est que voilà nous on veut vraiment
pousser le projet le plus loin possible
on pense que ça a vraiment un bon fond
et que ça peut vraiment avoir un impact
positif donc l'objectif c'est vraiment
de mettre tout le monde à l'aise avec
donc notre technologie you are modèle
pour que tout le monde puisse l'utiliser
au final alors du coup là donc vous êtes
dans ce concours quels sont justement
les prochaines étapes alors du coup là
on a eu donc la compétition je pense
qu'on a remporté donc là on monte dans
la compétition monde donc là dans
quelques jours on va passer la
demi-finale on aura les résultats il me
semble le 16 mai ensuite il y a la
finale qui se tient à Viva technology
donc via technologie c'est un
festival un festival de technologie
c'est un des plus grands d'Europe qui se
tient on a la chance qui tiennent à
Paris et donc si on passe en finale on
devrait pitcher donc notre projet devant
tous les membres et les visiteurs de
Viva technologies et donc ça ça se tient
en juin et justement vous êtes dans quel
état d'esprit aujourd'hui bah je pense
que ça fait un moment qu'on travaille
dessus et c'est vraiment un projet qui
nous tient à coeur parce que comme je
vous l'ai dit on croit vraiment que ça
peut plus que voilà permettre à L'Oréal
ou à une marque de
convaincre ses consommateurs on pense
vraiment que c'est un bon fond et que ça
peut vraiment faire du bien donc ça nous
tient vraiment à coeur donc on espère
aller plus loin possible et on se donne
vraiment les moyens on profite de de
toutes les opportunités et les
ressources que nous donnent L'Oréal pour
avancer sur notre projet qui sont
vraiment qui sont vraiment très utiles
et on croise les doigts pour pour les
prochaines étapes mais en tout cas on
croise tous les doigts pour vous merci
Marie landrevy de nous avoir présenté
votre projet on vous souhaite d'aller
justement au bout de ce concours
concours qui je le rappelle annoncera
les 10 derniers finalistes le 12 mai
prochain
et avec nous en plateau depuis ce début
ce début d'édition c'est géraldoucan
donc vous êtes le fondateur d'Alpha 7
drone et vous êtes basé à Maurepas vous
proposez des prestations de prise de vue
arrière alors quelles sont justement
toutes ces prestations parce que j'ai
justement votre carte et vous dites
faire de la photogrammétrie de
l'orthophoto qu'est-ce que c'est alors
ça c'est une partie assez technique déjà
dans le drone il y a deux catégories
dans la catégorie ouverte qui est basée
pour le loisir et la catégorie
spécifique qui est plus basée pour les
professionnels donc moi je vais parler
plus de la partie spécifique
professionnelle dont je fais partie donc
la photogrammétrie en fait c'est un
procédé de prise de vue de plusieurs
photos avec un chevauchement compris
entre aller 65 et 80%
et de là le sujet avec un logiciel bien
spécifique on peut le mettre en 3D donc
ça aide les architectes s'ils n'ont pas
la possibilité d'aller sur place de
faire des mesures et de pas polluer le
le chantier qui
d'être sur le chantier de polluer de
ralentir le chantier
et donc finalement vous vous souhaitez
vous diversifier vous n'êtes pas
spécialement spécifique à un domaine
vous pouvez faire justement comme vous
le disiez des prestations pour le grand
public donc ça peut aussi toucher des
mariages par exemple et bien un côté
professionnel
et vous avez d'autres aussi thématiques
pour l'instant je suis en face de
lancement et un peu de prospect de
prospection donc je suis ouvert toute
proposition que ça soit pour faire des
mariages de la prise de vue photos
prochainement je vais faire une
réalisation d'un reportage photo pour un
couvreur en région parisienne et après
pour les agriculteurs lors de dégâts de
d'animaux sauvages de sur leur culture
donc ça va il y a un panel énorme de
prestations à faire et comment ça se
passe justement le démarchage c'est
difficile de trouver des clients ou pour
l'instant c'est très difficile parce
qu'en fait les gens croient que le drone
s'est fait pour les espionner alors que
pas du tout on est là pour assurer la
sécurité on évite au cordiste de monter
à des hauteurs pas possible ou des
particuliers qui risqueraient de monter
de se casser le col du fémur donc on va
essayer d'éviter d'en manger les
urgences pour ça avec ça et non c'est un
gage de temps d'argent et de sécurité
alors je vais vous demander de pitcher
également votre activité la question en
fait c'est qu'est-ce que vous apportez
en plus qu'une personne qui a déjà en
possession d'un drone qu'est-ce que
quelle est la valeur ajoutée finalement
alors pour la partie spécifique en fait
moi je suis certifié de la formation
photographe donc ça je peux prétendre à
faire des suivis de chantier d'aller
prospecter les professionnels du BTP et
tout l'ensemble des professionnels que
ça soit
secours ou
le BTP en général et à la rédaction
également vous a préparé quelques
questions donc pour les téléspectateurs
qui qui souhaiteraient en savoir
davantage sur les normes puisque
utiliser un drone finalement c'est pas
il y a des interdictions il y a des
autorisations alors à quelle altitude
maximale est-ce qu'on peut faire voler
un drone alors là tout dépend de là où
on se trouve mais en règle générale si
on n'a pas de contre-indication c'est
120 mètres de hauteur
très bien et ce qu'il y a des espaces
qui sont interdits au vol et ce qu'il y
a des endroits particuliers à éviter
alors on a des restrictions que ça soit
tant
drone de loisirs on a des restrictions à
respecter notamment sur un portail drone
Géoportail pardon et on a la partie
spécifique ou quand on fait des
réalisations on fait des demandes
préfectorales et quand on est à côté
d'une d'un aéroport on est assujetti à
baisser la hauteur pour ne pas
interférer sur les couloirs aériens
est-ce qu'on peut voler à n'importe
quelle heure de la journée
deux jours comme de nuit pour la partie
loisir toujours elles doivent respecter
les la corne la nuit aéronautique donc
qui se passe
une demi-heure avant le lever du soleil
et une demi-heure après le coucher du
soleil
et en partie spécifique donc
professionnelle on doit faire des
déclarations préalables alors je vois
que vous aviez également apporté du
matériel est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus on a un drone on a un
casque alors ça c'est le don que
j'utilise en prestation ça c'est le
casque que je mets au client parce que
des fois ils veulent sentir la sensation
que ça fait de monter dans les airs de
voir un peu ce que on voit de haut donc
je leur mets le casque et ils en sont
ravis ça c'est la radiocommande que
j'utilise pour pour te piloter le drone
merci beaucoup Gérald de Toucan d'être
venu en plateau de pour nous faire
découvrir justement votre entreprise et
puis on vous souhaite de trouver plein
de clients et merci également de nous
avoir éclairé sur l'utilisation d'un
drone
le grand marathon des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 se joue dès maintenant les
Yvelines accueilleront plusieurs
disciplines l'un des enjeux de cet
événement c'est la sécurité et elle se
prépare dès aujourd'hui à Versailles une
école forme des élèves à la sécurité des
grands événements reportages de Ludivine
canard ils sont étudiants ou en
recherche d'emploi et après 106 heures
de formation ils pourront assurer la
sécurité de grands événements comme
Roland-Garros la Coupe du monde de rugby
ou les JO 2024
etc mais en fin de compte dès que je
suis rentré à la formation
le formateurs au programme notions
juridique gestion des risques
terroristes ou encore palpation et
formation au premier secours une
formation gratuite et rémunérée 11 euros
de l'heure 90 personnes seront formées
jusqu'au 30 septembre c'est devenu très
simple c'est possible et nous avons nous
ici à l'école européenne de sécurité
privée plus de 300 CDI à offrir notre
vrai obstacle en fait c'est tout
simplement de le faire savoir le secteur
de la sécurité recrute 13000 offres sont
disponibles dans la région mais il fait
face à des tensions c'est un secteur qui
dans ses effectifs à peu de femmes alors
que on aura aussi besoin d'elle pour
accéder à tous les événements et que ce
soit fluide qui est pas d'attente pour
pour les femmes qui viennent sur ces sur
ces manifestations seulement un quart
des candidats sont des femmes alors
qu'elles représentent près de la moitié
des visiteurs plusieurs autres
établissements de la région devraient
prochainement dispenser cette formation
et on va maintenant parler de secourisme
tout au long de la semaine nous vous
avons proposé une série de tutos sur les
gestes des premiers secours dans ce
troisième module le président
départemental de l'association croix
blanche 78 Bernard dabas nous explique
comment réaliser un massage cardiaque
Julien Leroy à la caméra
[Musique]
dans cette séquence on va voir comment
agir face à une personne adulte qui est
en arrêt cardio-ventilatoire j'arrive
près de la victime j'ai effectué la
protection elle ne saigne pas d'accord
serez-moi la main madame qui est des
yeux madame vous m'entendez il y a pas
de réponse elle est donc inconsciente
comme on l'a vu avant je bascule la tête
en arrière pour vérifier si elle respire
un ne respire pas je ne vois pas son
souffle je ne vois pas son ventre je me
sens rien elle est en arrêt cardio
ventilatoire là tout de suite ce qui
prime c'est d'alerter puisque la
meilleure chance de survie elle est liée
à l'arrivée précoce et secours donc on
demande à quelqu'un monsieur vous pouvez
aller alerter les secours et revenir
qu'à défibrillateur et on commence donc
le massage cardiaque si on a un nez tout
seul on met le téléphone sur
haut-parleur et on fait les deux en même
temps l'alerte et le massage là il va
falloir compresser le coeur pour faire
circuler le sang on va donc choisir
l'anime amère on déshabille la victime
ne pas toucher le patient l'appareil
vous dit de pas toucher donc je laisse
analyser
chaque conseiller ne pas toucher le
patient tout le monde s'écarte attention
écartez-vous là il y a un choc
électrique et on appuie sur le bouton la
victime peut bouger un petit peu et là
il y a toujours pas de
réaction donc je vais recommencer ma
réanimation et vous allez lui il y a un
métronome qui vous indique à quelle
vitesse masser
voilà et donc vous continuez les
compressions thoraciques tant que
l'appareil vous dit pas d'arrêter pour
relancer une analyse ou tant que les
secours ne sont pas arrivés
et on en parlait en début d'émission le
Nano satellite inspire 7 seven a décollé
le 15 avril dernier de la base
Vandenberg en Californie Patrice carmouz
est allé à la rencontre de Mustapha
Meftah le coordinateur des projets de
nano satellite il nous explique le
principe du lanceur regardez alors ça
c'est spécif alors ça c'est SpaceX c'est
avec cette fusée que inspire 7 a été mis
en orbite le 15 avril 2023 d'accord et
là pareil même chose je dévisse aussi et
vous étiez par là vous on était ici donc
vous avez le deuxième étage avec la
position des lanceurs alors là elle peut
pas se démonter mais on a ici une vue on
regardera après à l'intérieur de la
coiffe ok donc vous avez le deuxième
étage avec là et la particularité de
leur lanceur
c'est de pouvoir à un moment récupérer
cette partie donc vous voyez ici ces
éléments se déploient
ok on a des petits éléments et là ce
qu'il y a de génial c'est que on peut à
un moment lancer et la faire revenir au
sol oui on récupère
alors ça c'est pareil aussi une
particularité c'est que quand
Elon Musk et SpaceX propose cette idée
de récupérer un étage beaucoup on
considérait que ce n'était pas possible
bah visiblement c'est possible vu que
c'est ce qu'ils arrivent à faire donc ça
veut dire que il faut qu'on ait la même
chose en France en Europe avoir des
étages qui soient récupérables et donc
c'est pas parce que ça existe d'ailleurs
qu'il faut pas le faire au contraire il
faut y aller c'est fondamental pour un
élément clé c'est ce que l'on disait
c'est l'autonomie stratégique est-ce que
ce qui arrive souvent dans les nouveaux
nouvelles façons de créer d'inventer
est-ce que par exemple les le savoir
cactus SpaceX pour ramener
cet étage de la de la fusée
c'est il le garde pour eux ou c'est
diffusé c'est un là vous avez des choses
avec du secret industriel donc en
général le savoir est conservé alors bon
je tiens quand même à préciser dans le
SpaceX on sait ce qu'on appelle une
entreprise privée qui a réussi l'exploit
de mettre en orbite des dispositifs
assez rapidement mais ils ont des
investissements colossaux de l'État
américain donc ils ont eu des appuis qui
sont très importants pour y arriver donc
ils ont déjà mais il y a aussi la pluie
colossale de l'État américain alors je
reviens un peu en arrière
puisque là on est là oui alors ça c'est
cette partie c'est justement le deuxième
étage donc si vous le prenez aussi dans
la main là vous avez un moteur ici de
propulsion qui va pouvoir positionner à
un moment les satellites à une certaine
altitude donc à savoir que le premier
étage à un moment la séparation se fait
au bout d'une à deux minutes c'est au
bout de quelques minutes le premier
étage se sépare du deuxième étage et
vous avez ce dispositif lui qui va aller
à plus de 500 km d'altitude voilà 500
600 700 km d'altitude et puis à un
moment une des premières opérations
c'est de séparer ces deux éléments alors
je vous laisse faire essayer ez de les
enlever alors c'est une maquette mais
imaginez l'opération alors c'est une
translation vous devez les translater
puis vous allez voir que
je peux vous aider
vous voyez que imaginez ça dans l'espace
ça veut dire quoi translate
dans ce sens
comme ça
vous êtes un plat voilà donc vous voyez
que là on a les coiffes alors à
l'intérieur il y a généralement un
revêtement noir c'est pour éviter des
baisses en température
extérieure est blanche c'est ce qu'on
appelle un revêtement froid et puis une
fois que c'est en orbite vous êtes à 600
km d'altitude
[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page avec du jardinage
avec l'arrivée du printemps l'arboretum
de Versailles chèvreloux au Chesnay rock
en cours propose des ateliers pour
apprendre à semer vos fleurs comme des
professionnels un reportage signé Julien
Leroy ça c'est vraiment des organes de
réserve primitifs qui vont après ça
pourtant à la feuille de la sauce pas
toujours découverte d'une production
horticole pour les curieux de nature
dans ses serres de l'arboretum de
Versailles chèvreloux près de 60 000
végétaux sont semés à la main chaque
année pour fleurir le Jardin des Plantes
à Paris visite aux et ateliers sont
organisés au fil des saisons pour
présenter les coulisses de cette
activité les dernières années ont été
difficiles avec le covid et le on sent
quand même que le public voilà un besoin
en retour à la nature à toucher voilà
mettre les mains à la terre produire
essayer arrosage température luminosité
hygrométrie c'est cette jardinière bon
pu découvrir les secrets d'un
ensemencement professionnel chaque
graine est plantée grâce à un bâtonnet
imbibé d'eau afin de faciliter la prise
nous avons sont très différentes
techniques et surtout essayer de donner
des conseils pour que le public puisse
ensuite établir leur semis à la maison
et avoir un maximum de chances
d'obtenir de bons résultats grâce à au
conseil donné aujourd'hui c'est très
délicat parce que j'ai fait des
tentatives de germination chez moi et
bon bah j'ai fait des erreurs et je vais
directifier après la théorie place à la
pratique chacun a pu essayer à l'art du
semi en pot et repartir avec le fruit de
son travail encore un petit peu oui
on le fait avec les doigts j'ai choisi
des reines Marguerite et des zinnya qui
sont des fleurs très décoratives qui
montent à 70 cm de haut et qui vont
embellir mon jardin dans peu de temps
j'espère une prochaine visite des serres
horticole sera organisée ce mercredi 3
mai au Chesnay rock en cours l'occasion
de faire monter en graine ses
connaissances botaniques
et on a été rejoint par deux
journalistes de la rédaction TV 78
Michael midoro et Ludivine Camar bonsoir
bonsoir alors Michael et midoro vous
allez nous challenger sur un quiz
aujourd'hui sur quoi est-ce que vous
allez nous challenger alors sur le nom
des habitants des Yvelines et vous allez
voir dans quelques instants ils sont pas
forcément simples que ça à trouver et
avec vous Ludivine canard on vous
retrouve pour des idées de sortie pour
ce weekend d'ailleurs prolongé et on
commence à nouveau avec des chasses aux
œufs dans les Yvelines et oui le mois
d'avril n'est pas terminé la chasse aux
œufs peut donc continuer la ferme de La
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet
organise demain et jusqu'au 3 mai des
chasse aux œufs ramassés 6 œufs de
couleur différent tout en découvrant les
animaux de la ferme et repartez avec une
surprise en chocolat des initiations à
la chasse aux œufs avec des détecteurs
de métaux seront également proposés et
la maison des insectes située à
Carrières-sous-Poissy anime demain et
samedi deux ateliers oui le ce lien
intitulé Les Papillons du monde se
déroulera demain de 14h à 18h l'objectif
découvrir les origines des papillons qui
peuplent la serre samedi sera l'occasion
de comprendre pourquoi certains insectes
s'entraident et d'autres se font la
guerre des ateliers qui sont compris
dans le prix de la visite des ateliers
de découverte qui sont d'ailleurs
proposés jusqu'au 6 mai et vous nous
emmenez maintenant à Bougival pour une
balade artistique oui attirée par la
peinture en plein air et fan de monnaie
Renoir et Pissarro le parc Patrick
Vieljeux sur l'île de la chaussée à
Bougival vous invite dimanche pour une
visite guidée d'une heure trente sur les
pas des impressionnistes la visite est
conseillée à partir de 10 ans écoute 11
euros pour un adulte et 6 euros pour un
enfant et Ludivine maintenant vous nous
proposez un autre type de balade d'une
balade un peu plus sportive oui je vous
propose une balade cette fois à vélo
commenté au sein de la ville et du parc
de Versailles vous parcourez les
quartiers historiques et les grands
lieux de la ville la place d'Armes le
grand canal le canon ou encore la place
du marché en écoutant les explications
d'un guide de quoi les cultures et sport
durée de la balade 1h30 comptée encore
11 euros pour un adulte et 6 euros pour
un enfant et surtout n'oubliez pas votre
vélo et on termine avec une idée de
sortie qui pourra également intéresser
les sportifs oui le centre commercial au
shopping grand plaisir propose demain et
samedi à partir de 10h de nombreux
animations sportives et gratuites en
famille entre amis ou solo vous pourrez
vous initier à différents sports le mini
golf le tennis le tennis de table ou
encore le basket des athlètes du
territoire des Yvelines seront eux aussi
présents comme le cycliste Florian
grainbow l'objectif dynamiser les clubs
locaux
de pertes de licenciés et des journées
comme aujourd'hui ça ça permet de
revenir vers le public reposer nos
activités et puis avoir plus d'adhérents
et bien merci Ludivine canard pour ces
idées de sortie ce que vous avez été
inspiré
la visite de Bougival la balade très
intéressante
j'y suis allé plusieurs fois à carrière
sous Poissy et évidemment le sport aussi
à plaisir avec toutes ces animations
voilà si on fait un peu de sport le
week-end ça peut être pas mal non merci
en tout cas pour faire cette transition
c'est justement l'heure de notre
rendez-vous donc le quiz de la semaine
et ce n'est pas animé par Nicolas dandry
ni par Grégory canalet mais par vous
midet Michael el
misoro78 apparemment au niveau du quiz
en tout cas alors on commence tout
doucement avec une commune de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines situées à côté
de plaisir et de Villepreux je veux bien
sûr parler des clés sous bois comment
s'appellent les habitants des
Clayes-sous-Bois une commune de 17000
habitants
je vous laisse nous deux secondes pour
réfléchir des Clayes-sous-Bois si tu es
à côté de Villepreux et de plaisir
peut-être vous donner la parole je sèche
vous séchez
les clés
iens les clésiens
on va passer maintenant à la deuxième
question on va monter en niveau on va
parler du Chesnay Rocancourt une commune
de 31 1057 habitants nés d'une fusion au
1er janvier 2019 comment s'appellent les
habitants de la commune
[Musique]
tuchaînais Rocancourt
S
[Musique]
alors ce sont on va regarder la la
réponse pour l'instant zéro pas de
réponse les chênés courtois voilà
personne ne retrouve autour de cette
table bon vous étiez pas très très loin
quand même alors on passe maintenant à
la troisième question on va encore
monter en niveau on va parler de joui en
Josas une commune de
7983 habitants comment s'appelle les
habitants de la commune de Jouy-en-Josas
les Jonas
on va regarder tout de suite la réponse
les
Jovaciens donc pour régime vous étiez
pas très très loin mais bon
ça sera peut-être pour la prochaine
question on passe du coup à cette
quatrième question on va parler d'une
commune du nord des Yvelines le Vésinet
une commune de
15619 habitants comment s'appelle les
habitants de la commune du Vésinet
vous avez choisi aussi
mais quand même avec un petit piège à
chaque fois
je régime toujours pas
vous pouvez tenter
on va regarder tout de suite la réponse
les
vésigondants
on passe maintenant à la cinquième
question on va parler d'une commune du
nord des Yvelines Houilles une commune
de
33250 habitants comment s'appelle les
habitants de la commune les eaux-villois
les eaux-villois régime bravo
voilà on va regarder tout de suite la
confirmation à l'écran les eaux-villois
alors est-ce que vous savez pourquoi on
appelle ces eaux-villois les ovivois il
faut pas m'en demander Michael alors le
nom est venu du latin au viless qui
signifie mouton parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de moutons à l'époque voilà il
fallait savoir aussi on passe maintenant
à la sixième question on va parler d'une
commune de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Montigny-le-Bretonneux une commune de
militants commencent s'appellent les
habitants de la commune de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
on est c'est le trottoir d'en face
vous avez pas vu ça avant d'arriver non
pas du tout
mais non ce ne sont pas les Montignies
tout de suite la réponse
ce sont les inhymondins alors Régine
vous le saviez mais vous n'avez pas
répondu
alors c'est quand même pas simple on le
voit les noms des habitants des comics
c'est rarement simple on va voir si le
prochain vous allez le connaître on
passe à la septième question on va
parler d'une commune située à côté de
saint-germain-les Le Pecq une commune de
15 minutes 792 à 8 ans alors je vois
tout de suite que le nom de la commune a
suscité pas mal de réactions autour du
plateau comment s'appellent les
habitants de la commune du Pecq il y a
une magnifique je sais pas si ça peut
vous aider une magnifique église qui
s'appelle saint-vendrille ça vous aide
non pas du tout non alors ça monte
beaucoup peut-être que ben j'ai pas
trouvé la signification pour du nom du
gentillet pour le PEC mais la commune
monte beaucoup peut-être qu'il y a un
rapport en tout cas on régit on a une
proposition les pecs
non pas du tout alors on va regarder
tout de suite la réponse
les alpiquois peut-être en référence aux
Alpes je ne sais pas je n'ai pas eu la
la confirmation
dernier question on va parler d'une
commune du nom des Yvelines Croatie sur
scène une commune de 10000 324 habitants
comment les habitants de la commune
attention il y a eu qu'une seule bonne
réponse depuis tout à l'heure sur 8
questions
j'espère que l'équation j'espère que ça
va aller pour la prochaine
alors ce ne sont pas les croissants une
deuxième proposition peut-être Ludivine
les
non tenter tenter allez-y hein moi
j'aurais dit comme origine on dit comme
Régine
et bien malheureusement on va regarder
la rétro aussi Régine n'avait pas raison
c'était les croisillons croisillons
voilà j'espère que vous en savez un
petit peu plus sur les habitants des
Yvelines la prochaine fois on fera les
toutes petites communes des Yvelines
sûrement dans le quiz
merci Michael et demi et c'est
maintenant l'heure de jeter un dernier
coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
le ciel est très chargé dans tout le
département avec quelques précipitations
attendues dans la matinée du côté des
températures la douceur s'installe avec
14 degrés à ou dans Versailles et
Rambouillet et 15 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
ciel se dégage avec des éclaircies
partout dans le département au niveau
des températures on gagne entre 3 et 4
degrés avec 17 degrés à Rambouillet et
Versailles et 18 degrés à Houdan et
Mantes-la-Jolie et demain ce sera la
saint Valérie et pour les prévisions
météo de ce week-end c'est notre Mister
météo Thomas Fletcher qui prend les
commandes il nous parle de jazz dans ce
nouveau numéro de alors quoi de beau
regardez
alors maintenant bonjour à toutes et à
tous alors quoi de beau ce week-end
samedi c'est la journée de la danse
dimanche c'est la journée du jazz
aujourd'hui je suis accompagné
Mathis stagiaire pupitre
l'honneur de cette journée du jazz je
vais interpréter une musique je vais
interpréter du film là-haut parce que
j'aime bien ce film
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à bien voir
plus comme ça là
bouge pas juste
plus bas là
devant le visage comme ça je suis pas
perturbé
[Musique]
merci de m'avoir écouté j'espère que ma
prestation vous a plu maintenant on va
passer au micro de trottoir
on va passer au micro-trottoir et savoir
si vous aimez le jazz et si vous
connaissez quelques petits pas de danse
c'est parti
est-ce que vous vous écoutez un peu de
musique madame dites-moi d'abord qui
vous êtes je suis Thomas fetcherche
présente la météo du week-end de tous
les week-ends
est-ce que tu écoutes un peu de jazz
je connais pas
la boulette
du Hardy Iron Maiden tout ce qui bouge
quoi j'ai pris sur tout du carrelage
mon conseillerais un là c'est lequel je
sais pas encore écouté cela est-ce que
vous dansez un peu plus maintenant non
dans ce non ça c'était à l'époque de ma
jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
c'est très bien
vous pouvez pas faire la danse des
escalopes
[Rires]
on a dit des escalopes
OK
et tu le trouves comment franchement tu
peux le dire il y a pas la caméra
[Musique]
c'est plus dedans parce que là comme ça
peut-être parce que moi je l'ai pas du
tout c'est comme ça
[Musique]
merci pour tous ces mouvements deuxième
leçon la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
voilà alors c'était la météo de Thomas
flipcher notre Mister météo alors
j'espère que vous avez apprécié on est
passé de jazz à Michael Jackson
contre trottoir de Thomas flitcher et
bien c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission avant de se quitter et je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
aux conditions de circulation pour ce
weekend
ce week-end c'est le chassé croisé des
vacances pour la zone C mais c'est aussi
un week-end de trois jours avec le lundi
1er mai pour demain vendredi 28
l'Île-de-France est classée rouge par
Bison Futé dans le sens des départs les
premiers ralentissements sont attendus
pour la fin de matinée notamment en
direction des barrières de péage de
l'autoroute A10 il vous est donc plutôt
conseillé de quitter ou traverser la
région avant 12h samedi 29 le niveau de
trafic sera également moins sera
globalement moins important mais la
région est tout de même classique orange
prévoyez de partir avant 8h enfin lundi
1er c'est dans le sens des retours que
la circulation sera difficile en
Île-de-France prévoyez si possible un
retour avant 14h
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir été avec nous je vous souhaite
une belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin
de vous
[Musique]